another day in westminster closing in
the mood already gloomy the pm's
prospects darkening
covered restrictions passed on labour
votes as over a hundred of his own mps
defied him
the eyes to the right
369
the nose to the left 126.
this the most controversial of four
motions conservative mps refusing to
back clover passports are a negative
test to enter venues
the pm to parliament to press mps in
private the health secretary deployed to
make the case publicly for new
restrictions
omicron is a grave threat scientists
have never seen
never seen a covert 19 variant that's
capable of spreading so rapidly
when infections are rising so quickly
we're likely to see a substantial rise
in hospitalizations before any measure
is starting to have an impact so there
really is no time to lose
time for other restrictions to new laws
on face mask self-isolation and
mandatory jabs for nhs staff measures
many on these benches don't believe
necessary
we do not discriminate on a medical
basis in this country yeah and we cannot
i do not believe that this cobra
passports will prevent lockdown i think
the concept of learn to live with kovid
is as dead as anything i know
i can't support these measures and i
urge the government return to a society
of freedom and responsibility our
constituents deserve it and they will
rise to the challenge if this is going
to keep happening
how do we avoid being sat here in three
months time five months time six months
time debating the same thing what's the
plan
a pm boxed in trapped between a restive
party and a fast spreading variant
neither under his control
senior conservative mps say change or
calls for the pm's resignation could
begin
we've had a very bad month in the last
month
i think some members of the party will
be thinking to themselves we've got to
have a change you're saying that unless
the prime minister
changes his approach improves his
performance next year you think there
could be a leadership challenge i think
that's that's got to be on the cards and
he's got to realize that he's got to
change
this former chief whip instrumental in
rallying rebels tonight pushing for a
promise that any further restriction
should be decided by consulting
parliament
if it's during the recess and we have to
recall parliament that's what we should
do parliament must be taken seriously
not not just for the benefit of members
of parliament but for the benefit of our
constituents on behalf of whom we probe
ministers test the evidence and ask
important questions
the labour leader says mr johnson's no
longer fit for purpose well this is a
very significant blow to the already
damaged
authority of the prime minister it
confirms that he's
too weak to discharge the basic
functions of government
these public health measures
would not have gone through if labor
hadn't shown the leadership that the
prime minister failed to show
new coverage restrictions passed on the
back of labour votes the majority of the
public in favor too
but many conservative mps are not and
tonight the prime minister suffered his
biggest rebellion yet
but this is as much about principle and
style as policy scandals around sleaze
and parties has cost this pmdr as one
former ally put it to me boris johnson
has just used up eight of his nine lives
one life left how he handles his next
crisis critical not just for the country
but for his premiership too